are you kidding me what the [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh hey how's the gown breast
my name's Ben welcome oh boy oh boy are
we gonna build some [ __ ] do you like
building [ __ ] I do too every day me too
let's do this
scrap mechanic what's our world name
Minecraft
we can build vehicles oh my god that's
awesome okay breasts are you ready to
build the greatest car this town has
ever known
there's not even a town that's why it's
the greatest one BAM
holy [ __ ] this car is going to be so
good produce up and down oh that was the
most erotic experience of my life jesus
[ __ ] christ what just happened
Oh whew well that's some good [ __ ]
all right we're building this we're
build this city we're built this city oh
my god
oh it's so satisfying let's let's do it
again oh oh whoa laughs okay okay let's
just put a wheel on that [ __ ] yeah yeah
you like that don't you
that's that's that's my car right there
am I doing this right Brum Brum Brum
Brum oh wow this is the mascot I think
we're gonna have to take a look at the
manual again and see that we do this
right I like to ride hide baby I'm not
gonna lie when these holds up in the
club they'd be riding dirty
now let's just get in make sure you
remove the lift best car this town how
do I get up there oh my god
yeah we built the car pros now let's
where's my sunglasses I don't have any
uh now let's run Oh
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] dammit god dammit [ __ ]
[ __ ] I put so much effort all right all
right all right calm down no hey hey oh
god oh god it's got its own will
oh god it's gonna it's gonna kill us all
I must stop it no no stop it
[ __ ] no we must not let it reproduce
this technology the science it's not cut
off with that god damn it ah oh god ah
ah well that was close ah ah
oh [ __ ] alright let's build another one
let's put the seat here here we go [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] ah ah
[ __ ]
goddamn it hurts it hurts my whole body
ah oh [ __ ] my mom warned me about this
alright uh you know how about we just
start up from ground up to Ground Zero
all right oh my God look how many [ __ ]
you can build you can build a toilet
what the [ __ ] man alright
we're building a flying toilet right
here right now on the port-a-potty
oh my god oh my god yep we're building
this
now that is the face of a man sitting on
a toilet to space yeah nail that [ __ ]
also we got a set maximum thruster all
right you bros ready for this oh my god
scared okay all right can we get a
countdown can we get a countdown on this
[ __ ] this is gonna be the best [ __ ]
rocket ship you've ever seen in your
goddamn life
look at this man he's so pumped he
trained his whole life for this his
whole career has gone up to this point
he's got one chance in life to really
prove himself for his family here we go
oh my god this is the worst countdown I
have ever seen in my entire life all
right here we got 10 all the
second-stage tanks now pressurized 35
seconds and counting
we are still vehicle 30 seconds and
counting whoa
three two one liftoff are you kidding me
what the [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] my leg up oh my god Bali [ __ ] holy
[ __ ]
oh I'm crying I was [ __ ] beautiful
I'm so glad I was not on that rocket
[ __ ] was [ __ ] beautiful Oh
rest in peace rocket ship probably
shouldn't have deleted the whole [ __ ]
thing alright here we go
ah we have reached we had reached the
NetherRealm we have reached the other we
cross the other side what the [ __ ] was
that I'm fine what the [ __ ] was it oh
god oh god we're crashing we're crashing
mom my brush I'll have you know I love
you we'll never forget you
this is said hey I'm actually fine
all right bros I hope you enjoyed this
video if you did go ahead and leave a
like it always helped and I appreciate
it thank you so much for watching and as
always stay awesome breasts